welcome to this video and playing mmm
Cal gpk from the UK to 264 yep a night
off I recently saw ii 5 @ h5 played
against that thought this was funny h5
to prevent any g4 plans ok so
interesting it's playing the night to g3
attacking the palm
it doesn't really look great to me why
does he play 93 I mean I don't think
that advancing here brings any any sort
of benefit and do you really want to go
back and block your bishop this looks so
strange 93 yeah this is possible but if
I go if I take g3 and take F 2 and this
go check so it's equal material but he's
got this strange king ok I need to cover
b6 and c7 song return but I can just
play knight c6 Bishop e6 developed
normally maybe I could have could have
thought about the check because if I was
hanging hmm maybe ok let's um develop I
could
can I take on h3 here and Queen h4 check
yeah I think I can why not takes Queen
edge for check check it looks some very
dangerous we cannot go to g1 or g2
because of Queen h3 queen a king f3
that's 94 so he probably needs to go to
e3 and then I have Queen g5 check and
rook h3 now it's a at least a very
tricky and a practical game um can also
just castle check yeah let's let's check
first
so look here look f3 I can play Queen g2
something like that hmm check that I
need to take not not much choice the
question is if I have something better
here yeah there's always the the check
of course
yeah it's probably not not full
compensation all this but okay it's got
a king on d3 there's always some some
play check
green here this Queenie to ya okay so
probably yeah I probably need to cancel
him need to get out of this this bloody
threat will offer 97 yeah this
unfortunately limits my night
what can I do we have general I can play
g6 f5 using the pawns on I could try
some direct direct things
hmm need I need this rook I need this
look into play I think I need to try use
the the pieces you still have got slide
coordination issues Queen h2 probably
not this is hanging maybe just g6 you
come on let's just play c6f5 the Sun is
a move anyway and maybe I've got look H
for Luke g4 or something like that yeah
I'm fishing here this wasn't a correct
sacrifice not at all
I cannot even play a five now I probably
need to even with g6 hanging what what
else
hmm I didn't take that into account
you know Glee c7 isn't made yeah yeah
check
well there are some little tricks queen
rock h2 is one of them Bishop d7 look p7
Queen sizzix that the Seb Seb CIF one is
hanging you cannot take it anyway and
rock edge to was some some IDM I think
I'm not sure maybe he should have played
it in a more more technique technical
manner not trying to meet me I have a
bit a bit of play here not not like
enough but some way to at least irritate
him look h2 is one of them but it's not
a real threat here again yeah this is a
move that he can play but why why am i
exactly here I mean now be two is really
hanging he can of course always draw
with community 7 but the draw is much
more than I deserve him now he must draw
now what
check down no I'm just winning check
checkmate yeah he must he must draw of
course I have everything one I mean no
word out about that he's taking this
back oh yeah white white was completely
winning it's no no argument um he could
simply a play as he did just escaping
with the King and Dwight is better
Bishop h3 was a nonsense move it looked
interesting I mean I completely
underestimated this I can just play a
play a normal move like let's say here
it should be six and it's it's a normal
position why I like black because of the
better pawn structure he's got this this
week porn but it's not nothing
particularly special the way it went
down and i was lost and was lucky that
he didn't want to accept the draw all
right lucky win thanks for watching